flipping it around to the carolina
panthers when
they gave a top of tier two contract
last year to teddy bridgewater three
years 66 million a lot of people were
like holy crap
and it looked like they were going to be
tied to bridgewater for at least two
years when you consider
the guaranteed money and the cap charge
and they're still looking at 10 million
fully guaranteed in salary this year for
teddy bridgewater
but whatever it was whatever he did
whatever in the film room
caused matt rule and or david tepper and
or scott federer
to say enough's enough teddy got one
year
and that's that and it's not even a
matter of let's see if we can clean it
up let's see if we can fix it up he
didn't have christian mccaffrey for most
of the season if he has mccaffrey maybe
he can better
they were done for as much as they loved
him a year ago shireen
they were able to decide in one season
this is not our guy
and now it's just a matter of time
before he's a former
member of the carolina panthers but the
reality is if they don't find someone
to take him via trade and take that 10
million dollars in guaranteed money
they may have to just keep him around as
a backup you may have a situation where
you've got a starter who's making about
4 million
and you've got a backup who's making
well over 10 million it's 10 million
guaranteed and i think let's see what
more there is on top of it it's 17
million all together
in salary so uh you could have a backup
who is making dramatically more
than the starter this year in carolina
if they can't find a trade partner and
if they don't want to eat that 10
million dollars in guaranteed money
yeah and i started going down the list
of teams mike where he potentially would
have a chance to go and start and there
just
really aren't that many options i mean
maybe new england but i'll see new
england trading forum
panthers decide to move on and cut him
that that might be a possibility but i
you know i just don't know that there's
going to be a trade partner out there
for teddy bridgewater you know what
would be a great landing spot i would
love to see for teddy
it's tampa bay because you look at what
teddy did in new orleans behind
drew brees and i think he's an upgrade
on the backup quarterback situation
in tampa maybe he's their future
quarterback if it doesn't work
out behind him if they can't draft that
guy
over the next couple years maybe teddy
gets that chance but that to me would be
a fascinating
place to see teddy go either tampa or
new england
would be a place but i as far as going
somewhere and starting
i don't see that mike do you no
no uh unless on
one one possibility would be for him to
go to the 49ers and be
the stop gap short-term bridge to number
three overall
that's one possibility so you unload
jimmy garoppolo
at 25 acquire teddy bridgewater at
17. and then everyone knows going in
teddy's just holding the spot until mac
jones justin fields trey lance or
whoever is ready to go
that's the one way that i think that
would happen and if i recall correctly
and there's a good chance i don't the
49ers did reportedly
inquire about a potential teddy
bridgewater trade here's the other thing
and i'll agree with you completely on
the possibility of teddy bridgewater
going to the tampa bay buccaneers it was
last year
that bruce arians the coach of the tampa
bay buccaneers told
peter king following the signing of tom
brady
they had narrowed down their wish list
quarterback
to three guys one tom brady
three jameis winston two
teddy bridgewater so the idea of getting
bridgewater
to take the place of blaine gabbert now
if he would be cut by the panthers
look anything less than 10 million
dollars he's playing for free
because he's getting the 10 million from
the panthers no matter what
less whatever he makes somewhere else
but he could really stick it to the
panthers if he wanted to they cut him
he goes to tampa takes 2 million
panthers are paying him eight million
dollars to be the backup to tom brady
and to stake his claim
to potentially be the successor to brady
and tampa bay
and even though teddy bridgewater has
been around for a while now he's in his
early 30s
he's more than 10 years younger than tom
brady so you're still
you're still going significantly younger
when tom brady walks away
and then bridgewater can be the guy
until you exhaust whether or not he can
truly get it done long term and if it
doesn't work long term then you move on
to someone else so
i think you're onto something with the
buccaneers i think the 49ers are another
possibility
i think if the seahawks decide to trade
russell wilson bridgewater is a guy who
would be a better option than anyone
else they currently have available
so the the seats are getting limited
and and uh now that darnold is taking
the presumptive starting role in
carolina teddy's going to be moving on
shireen but i
look i think we've seen enough from him
in recent years
and i saw enough from him last year and
i am stunned how quickly they fell
out of love with teddy bridgewater i
think there's enough there for him to
get a shot somewhere else
yeah and mikey is 28 and he doesn't turn
29
until november so he is still young he
has 59 career starts he has a pro bowl
we know that beca that came before the
devastating knee injury
but this is a guy potentially who could
get better and better
off of that knee injury you know just
recovering and being on the field and
getting those reps
that that he didn't get in his third
year in his fourth year we know how long
it was between his starts so i think
there's still a future there for teddy
bridgewater and if i'm a team like the
buccaneers i'm absolutely moving on him
which is potentially mike why carolina
sits on him and says we don't want to
believe him we don't want him going to a
division rival like the buccaneers and
potentially being
unless they're going to trade for him
potentially being the hair apparent to
tom brady we don't want that so we'll
just hold on to teddy see if sam's any
good and we always had the potential to
put teddy back in the lineup we know
what he is
i got one for you that it just occurred
to me
who's the general manager of the denver
broncos right now
oh yeah barry george george payton
right-hand man of rick spielman when
teddy bridgewater was drafted by the
vikings at number 32 in 2014 the johnny
manzo year the vikings had the private
workout fell in love with him
and it was just one of those stuff
happens
in the worst possible way that ended
teddy bridgewater's time with the
vikings the horrific knee injury
late august 2016.
and then his contract ran out they're
not going to make him the starter going
forward nobody knew what he was going to
do nobody knew how healthy he was going
to be he's reestablished himself
i remember a time he went to denver 2014
2015-ish and beat the broncos with the
vikings it would have been 14 i think
i think if i recall correctly for some
reason that sticks out in my head i'm
going to do my research during the break
or while you're talking multitask
i do i do vaguely recall maybe they lo
oh they lost
it was a close game in denver that they
lost on a von miller strip sack
of teddy bridgewater that's what it was
it was a close game and the vikings were
driving so
i could see the broncos who clearly
aren't enamored with drew locke because
number one he can't stay healthy on a
consistent basis he's got the jimmy
garoppolo fragile gene all due respect
but if you can't stay healthy that's
just the reality you're going to get
criticized for that
and number two when he has played he
hasn't consistently been great
bridgewater could be the next domino
that falls from eight to nine as the
broncos realize you know what
we're not going to get a franchise
quarterback in the top 10
either because of this run that's coming
at the top four or five spots
let's just go ahead and take teddy
bridgewater if they can work that out
and then the panthers if they could do
something where bridgewater
would rework his contract and they could
hand her to the broncos
and avoid a situation where he's cut and
he goes to tampa bay
not that the buccaneers would ever you
know tamper and put ideas in his head
teams don't do that but if they could
pull this off then it never gets to the
point where he ever does realize hey i
could just sit tight get cut and go play
for the buccaneers
but being the backup to tom brady versus
being the starter in denver
even if there's a chance to eventually
start in tampa
hard to say no to a chance to go to
denver and be the starter right away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports